[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKUR KOTWAL: You've
got a great brand,
and you want everything on
your app or site to match it.
With custom styling, you can
change the look of your maps
to suit your needs.
Hi, I'm Ankur Kotwal.
And in this episode,
I'm going to show you
how awesome the Google
Maps API custom styling is.
We'll also look at
a new tool to help
you create your own styles.
So let's start off by looking
at what custom styling is.
So here is a normal Google map.
It looks cool in the
daytime, but here's
how it could look at night.
Now, let's say you
have an app that's used
for tracking bicycle rides.
And in that use case,
providing a great experience
in the evening is just as
important as the daytime.
Wouldn't it be great to
have the app automatically
switch to the Night theme on
the map at the appropriate time?
Now, when we saw
that happen, it's
important to see that that
style was applied to the map
instantly.
We didn't need to tear
down and rebuild the map.
It just immediately
adjusted to the new style.
Custom styling puts you in
control of the colors that
are used in the map.
You can use this to
enforce your branding,
to match your taste
in colors, or focus
on what's more important.
You describe a custom
style using JSON.
And you only have to do it
once, because the same style
format is supported across
the web, Android, and iOS.
Now, since it's
just a JSON file,
you can store it
where you'd like.
It can ship with your app,
or you can download and apply
the style dynamically
at run time.
So how do you create
a custom style?
Well, some developers
will tell you
that you should create these
JSON files in Vim, Emacs,
Sublime Text, so whatever
your favorite text editor is.
And you could.
But for those of us that
want something more visual,
we've created a
Styling Wizard for you.
The Styling Wizard is
available at this URL,
and it's a tool that makes it
easy to build your own custom
map styles.
Now, what we've done here
is group the styling options
into logical categories.
And when you change
these values,
the Styling Wizard reflects
that change immediately.
What's cool is that the Styling
Wizard includes a few default
styles.
The Night style is useful
for those evening use cases,
like our bike ride app.
And Silver is great
if you want to provide
a subtle or toned-down look.
But my favorite by far
is the Retro style.
So once you've created
your style with the Wizard,
you're going to
want to apply it.
Now, we're going to look
at a few code snippets
to show you how easy it
is to apply the styles
across all three platforms.
Let's start with the web.
To modify the styles
of the default
map types, set the style
array in the Maps MapOptions,
either at the time
of construction
or by calling map.setOptions.
On Android, to
style your map, call
googleMap.setMapStyle and pass
in a MapStyleOptions object.
That's going to contain your
style declarations in the JSON
format.
You can also load the JSON from
a raw resource or a string.
On iOS, to apply custom
map styles to the map,
call GMSMapStyle to create
a GMSMapStyle instance.
You can pass in a URL
for a local JSON's file
or a JSON string containing
style definitions.
Then just assign the
GMSMapStyle instance
to the MapStyle
property of the map.
Earlier, I stated that
you can use custom styles
to focus on what's important.
Let me explain what
I meant by that.
Custom styling allows
you to hide labels,
or vary road density, or even
toggle points of interest.
And the way you do this
is by tweaking the style
options in the Styling Wizard.
What we do is click More
Options, select a category,
and then tweak as appropriate.
You can also use the predefined
styles as a starting point
and then create your
own unique map style.
So there you have it.
Custom styles are a great
way to tailor your maps
to your unique taste and brand.
The Styling Wizard makes it easy
to create custom map styles,
and then you can apply
them just as easily
at run time on the
web, Android, and iOS.
To learn more, check out
the docs at this link.
And to get started, check
out the sample code here.
Share your styled maps
with the hashtag #mapstyle.
We're looking forward
to seeing your styles.
Thanks for watching.